[Música]
hola como estan soy pablo hernández o
hegel y hoy quiero darles muchos años de
conocimiento que yo tengo a lo largo de
hacer mi sueño realidad y quiero
enseñarles cómo hacer realidad cualquier
objetivo que ustedes tengan en su mente
y en su corazón hoy quiero hablarte cómo
lograr tus sueños
cuáles son mis secretos que ha aprendido
yo de las mentes más brillantes con las
que he convivido y de las que he leído a
lo largo de los últimos años después de
haber ido a cursos con tony robbins
haber aprendido de la mano el mes
después
de haber leído cientos y cientos de
libros y hoy tengo mucho conocimiento
que compartirles
lo principal y lo que más quiero
decirles es que creo que nosotros como
seres humanos e individuos somos los
maestros y los controladores de nuestro
destino en la historia de la humanidad
hemos visto como hay hombres que han
hecho cosas increíbles
han dejado una huella creo firmemente
que el éxito deja huella y que todos los
que nosotros logramos en nuestra vida
está en nuestra mente
todas nuestras ideas al final del día se
convierten en una energía que surge
desde adentro de nosotros y esa idea se
convierte en una acción y esa acción se
convierte en resultados esta foto que
pueden ver soy yo cuando tenía 22 años
es un sábado cuando yo arranqué mi
negocio tenía 14 años y tuve la suerte
de aprender a hacer páginas web a esa
edad creo firmemente
que todo esto no ha sido fruto de la
casualidad ha sido el fruto de una
visión y de entrenarme constantemente a
mi niño para poder sobrevivir todo el
rol del claustro qué significa ser un
emprendedor el mejor entrenamiento que
puedes hacer para ser un emprendedor
exitoso y no sólo eso un buen esposo un
buen padre un buen deportista y un buen
ciudadano global
y deje una huella y un gran impacto para
el mundo es entrenar tu mente
y yo pienso que a dónde va tu mente
sigue en tu cuerpo y a dónde van tus
pensamientos va tu vida
por eso las ideas y lo que pasa nuestra
mente es lo que acaba sucediendo adentro
hay una vida increíble
adentro de nuestras mentes
que permite que nosotros logremos lo que
queramos dentro de las fuerzas de la
naturaleza dentro de lo que es posible y
yo creo firmemente
me ha inspirado mucho en muchos libros
que he leído que nuestro
ingenio nuestra creatividad todo lo que
nace dentro de ti todas estas ideas
pueden tomar formas de una idea que no
es tangible al mundo físico y creo que
eso sí nosotros entendemos que cuando
nosotros tenemos un resultado en nuestra
vida sea que tengamos mil pesos en
nuestra cuenta de banco o un millón de
pesos
con quien estemos casados con quienes
estemos que sea el resultado que hayamos
logrado con nuestra vida
si hemos logrado nuestros sueños o no
todo eso ocurre en nuestra gran mente de
aquí nacen las ideas que se convierten
en las acciones de todos los días y por
eso es tan importante
cuidar nuestra mente el cuerpo es uno de
los
instrumentos
más
increíbles de la creación
y dentro de nosotros
platicaba mucho con bob proctor hay dos
tipos de personas y bou dice que hay los
optimistas positivos y las personales
negativas
esta gente positiva es la gente que
siempre está viendo para adelante que no
permitas que el miedo la conquiste y las
personas negativas están siempre
atoradas quejándose en y son realmente
personas que realmente a veces no logran
tener los grandes resultados la gente
que ha sido muy exitosa en su vida es o
es optimista es positiva siempre ve cómo
está brillando el sol y cómo hacer cosas
padres
nosotros tenemos libre albedrío para
elegir en cuál de estos lugares podemos
caer y solitos con conciencia podemos si
está saturado en un ciclo negativo con
tiempo y con calma puedes moverte a un
lado positivo
yo estoy consciente
100% convencido que lo que nosotros
creamos en nuestra mente es el resultado
que vamos obteniendo y por ende las
acciones producen resultados alguien que
corre un maratón es el fruto de tomar
una decisión en su mente
levantarse y ponerse entrenar durante
meses con constancia pero tiene de una
idea correr un maratón es algo que se te
ocurre y que requiere acciones y esas
acciones es comprar unos tenis
tener ropa entrenar tal vez encontrar un
grupo de corredores inscribirte a una
carrera y entrenar con el
entrenamiento adecuado y con la
disciplina y cualquier ser humano puede
entrenarse para ser un maratón o un arma
si nosotros entendemos esto que
cualquiera
podría correr un maratón con sólo el
hecho de pensarlo y después seguir esos
pasos y ahí después de varios meses
el resultado es llegar a la meta con una
medalla porque corres un maratón y lo
mismo pasa con la carrera profesional y
con los sueños son decisiones son ideas
todo nace aquí adentro y si nosotros
entendemos eso esos pensamientos crean
la realidad de nuestra vida y obviamente
hay circunstancias afuera leyes de la
naturaleza de cómo funciona el mundo
desde la ley de la gravedad y la
consciencia de que las cosas que
necesitan acción las ideas solas no
hacen nada las ideas necesitan ir
acompañadas de un plan de un deseo y de
fuego y de ganas de hacer que se hagan
realidad pero todos los resultados que
tú tienes en tu vida son las causas de
lo que pasó aquí y si tú ya fija es
crear una agencia de marketing digital o
ser dueño de tu propio negocio como era
mi plan te van a salir muchas puertas
que se te van a cerrar y muchos que
estaban abrir y tu mentalidad tiene que
ser
si tú logras tener esta mentalidad
imparable
cuando te pongan un obstáculo te digan
que no obtengas un problema con
optimismo vas a buscar otro lugar de
cómo resolver sin rendirte porque
nuestros pensamientos crean nuestra
realidad entonces tú eres el dueño tu
destino si tú quieres
caer en la idea de que
estamos complicadas las cosas por las
que jeans te vas a comprar en aquel
jeans y tus resultados
vas a empezar a traer ese tipo de cosas
porque es lo que tu mente está esperando
sin embargo las grandes empresas se han
hecho en las bicis y esto que estos
individuos estos emprendedores estos
luchadores tenían una idea en su mente y
no permitían que el mensaje de crisis
los llevara y empiezan a crear su propia
realidad en base a lo que ellos quieren
construir
han estado esto nada más el pit coin
nació en la mente de alguien las
computadoras nacieron en la mente de
alguien el iphone fue una creación
hablar en la mente de steve jobs
los coches nacen en la mente y de la
mente pasan a una forma física lo mismo
thomas alva edison tenía en su mente el
hacer el foco e intentó más de 10.000
veces hasta que lo logró yo no sé si
ustedes sabían pero
edison tuvo tres meses de educación
formal y
además y son más de 100 patentes más de
100 inventos
edison y henry ford eran muy amigos si
ustedes quieren ser exitosos en su vida
y lograr cosas que tengan un impacto en
el mundo tienen que rodearse de gente
que sea como ustedes y que tenga esa
pasión y ese fuego y que los lleve
tienen que tener un grupo y que los
empujes a los mejores
también si pensamos en el avión el otro
día venía manejando y recogiendo a mi
hijo de la escuela y decía papá
y mira sacó su mano por la ventana y el
aire la levantó tan tétrico papá quien
entendí cómo vuelan los aviones a ver
acelerar un poquito más y sus manos y
vamos para arriba a haber baja le para
eso es algo que el entendimiento va
llegando a nuestra mente y así es como
podemos crear cualquier ser humano está
con esta capacidad todos los seres
humanos que han vivido en este planeta
tienen las mismas
ventajas tenemos un cerebro y tenemos
una capacidad de usar nuestra
imaginación luz y ver un día a alguien
se le ocurrió hacer hot cakes ponerles
fresas y miel todo lo que vemos es algo
que surge con nuestra imaginación y con
nuestra intuición desde los relojes
desde las obras arquitectónicas o las
obras de arte todo esto está en nuestra
mente y por eso nosotros tenemos que ser
guardianes de nuestros pensamientos ir
entrenando nuestra mente y nuestro
subconsciente para hacer lo que nosotros
queramos hacer en la vida
[Música]
en la década de los 60s me llama
muchísimo la atención y me encanta esta
historia del presidente kennedy
diciendo que fuera a la luna
si se acuerdan la última imagen esa
computadora que ocupaba un cuarto es una
computadora de los sesentas y para poner
una computadora chiquitita en un cohete
no existe en computadoras chicas
el presidente kennedy le pregunto al
doctor von braun que era él quien dirige
el programa espacial enlace en su
momento quién estamos para llegar en una
la voluntad para hacerlo towards tu ex y
cuando tú te pones un objetivo grande
que te dé miedo que te ponga incómodo
que no tengas ni idea de cómo lo vas a
conseguir
con voluntad sucede magia en tu vida y
suceden cosas increíbles y muchas veces
se nos olvida que estamos en un pequeño
planeta dentro de un cosmos y de una
galaxia increíble y el mismísimo doctor
von braun en 1936 dijo
el universo es
espectacular ver todos estos misterios y
como el tamaño del cosmos y la galaxia
si puedan después busquen en youtube el
vídeo de carl sagan de pequeño punto
azul porque muchas veces nos levantamos
intrusivo y la mañana que te levantas te
estoy seguro que lo cruzo por tu mente
que eres el pasajero en una nave
espacial enorme que le llamamos tierra
que estamos girando alrededor del sol en
un cosmos espectacular y cuando nos
damos cuenta de eso que todos tenemos
una misión en nuestra vida para hacer
cosas grandes y que la forma de
descubrirlo es a través del silencio y
la intuición
entonces no solo es que tú quieras ser
exitoso por tener mucho dinero claro que
el dinero es increíble y yo prefiero
tener dinero que no tenerlo cuando no lo
tiene que el sufrido prefiero mil veces
tener algo de dinero
pero no lo es todo hay muchas cosas
que pueden que podemos hacer para que
tener un mundo mejor a mí me apasiona
crear inventar que otras personas tengan
acceso a la educación y a los mentores
que yo he tenido que puedas dar muchos
empleos en el mundo que podamos crear
valor que ponce en este planeta hace un
mejor planeta para los demás entonces
ustedes tienen que entrenar a su mente
ya su subconsciente para pensar que ya
están ahí yo desde el día uno
que fundó en mi agencia digital sabía
que iba a trabajar con las marcas más
importantes
visual y sé que iba a tener una compañía
grande y me la creía desde el día uno
que yo iba a vender a mis 18 años 19
años 23 años me vestía de traje
dada esa percepción porque de que éramos
una compañía grande porque yo ella me
visualizaba y entonces visualicen se
cree en una imagen de ustedes mismos que
toman las las imágenes de lo que tengan
y vayan constantemente a ellos quiero
decirles que
una de las personas que más se admiran
mi vida es don lorenzo servitje quien
tuve el honor de llevar una gran
relación de amistad y de mentoría era mi
mentor y esta es una foto de un día que
fue a visitar
había sólo una frase en su oficina que
era él y twitter
rice puerta pero en abertis hoy estamos
firmando esta sesión a las seis de la
mañana en un sábado a mí me gusta
arrancar temprano les recomiendo
muchísimo que si ustedes quieren ser
exitosos en su vida sean consistentes
arranquen temprano duerman bien sigan el
método de ravi sharma que pone en el
libro the fire lou 20 minutos de
silencio oración meditación
20 minutos de ejercicio de realmente
sudar y 20 minutos de estudio
si ustedes
si en esta rutina que muchos
[Música]
gente que ha sido exitosa y que ha hecho
algo de impacto en el mundo la sigue van
a poder llegar muy lejos y obsesionarse
por repetidamente estudiar
obsesivamente
sueñan en grande piensan en grande estos
son varios remedios los favoritos de los
que aprendido muchísimo y de verdad
creen que nada es imposible
ustedes en su mente definen su destino
ustedes deciden si quiere ser
astronautas e ir a la luna si quieren
poner un puente
que lleve a ser humano a marte si
quieren crear el siguiente auto
eléctrico no limiten su capacidad
creativa de verdad créanme lo he vivido
lo experimentado en carne propia he
hecho cosas increíbles en mi vida me he
sentado con
billonarios con artistas con medallistas
olímpicos hasta un sueño mío con un
ganador del tour de france
ustedes
tienen
límites más que los que se ponen en su
mente entonces crean sela y vivan una
vida de disciplina de también
flexibilidad para poder innovar pero
entiendan que como acabas haciendo
cualquier cosa como acabas haciendo todo
y que donde ustedes pongan sus
pensamientos es donde van a poner sus
acciones y serán los resultados que
tendrán y es lo que harán consumir